salut bienvenue aux 21 30 du mental blog
c'est parce que je pense un chef de la
belle île en bus
soyez nos coutumes et soyez nos gros
cigare technique pas un soir 32 32 32 32
ouais coucou coucou le moins viril du
monde
c'était simplement la voile en aurons
des loges à nico rien je change ça vole
son salut salut bouder chinguar tapiès 3
4 fois le sens où c'est l'équipe
j'avais d'abord faire la bise à ta
caméra devrait lui ça va mais amenés à
inglourious passé trop bien faire des
visées laquelle gérard
madame véronique ce soir nous avons
c'était
monsieur jason 'brokers' alors je prends
ça photo wenn nous avons donné le jack
smales donel jack'sman voilà nous avons
oui mais là pour le coup tu as autant
lui ai promis plus tôt
et oui des geeks manomètres jackman nous
avons aussi très bien oui car évidemment
la mairie car notre bien dit que nous
avons bouder vous devrez vous des rangs
plus il est où il est tout aussi chic et
l'a réparé à temps la fille est là elle
est bien faite
s'il affiche qui bouge pas c'est la plus
grosse affaire frédéric séguéla je me
suis promené dans les loges
je ne sais pas du tout par où passait
mais non pas par là que je voulais celle
ci permet à l'appareil
cube il s'installe
pas besoin d'eux c'est dans la boîte ce
à quoi je n'essaie même pas de quoi
parlera de ses biens comme celles
faisant un trou que je veux à chaque
fois je m'étais derrière on n'a pas
besoin d'eux esteban qui va me poser des
questions moi j'ai dit ok je répond à
des questions que si je peux de bloguer
alors moi aussi je vais te poser des
questions c'est cool c'était cool parce
que le public de l'hymne glorious il est
hyper bienveillant il est hyper
chaleureux c'était vraiment très très
bien pourquoi tu as toujours une escale
pour tenir mes cheveux pour tous non
mais t'as rien je peux aussi sinon on
fait ce qu'on aime dans les ponts dans
les yeux on se rend compte que c'est
justin bieber là c'est parce qu'il est
sur un plateau d'humour ici c'est qui va
morfler si on voit ces choses 12 ans est
sûre ce soir j'ai fait un petit peu trop
long sur scène je devais faire douze
minutes j'ai fait 17 minutes mais j'ai
trouvé mon maître oui dès qu'il s'agit
de faire long c'est évidemment moi le
maître en la matière mais je n'ai pas
faim le lendemain j'étais dans les temps
gervinho j'étais dans les temps j'étais
dans les temps vous savez été très très
haut avant les élus oui pour les
ateliers début de saison avant de faire
cette étude des 25 qui c'est sûr que je
me rends pas compte et en fait voilà
évident
dix ans à la bible et ça va c'était je
crois que je le connais depuis 2010 et
depuis 2010 il dit à comprends pas mon
portable je crois que les fonctions qui
dit [ __ ] deux artistes 47 minutes
tournée on peut payer des suds possible
non non non sinon j'aurais arrêté depuis
longtemps
c'est juste que tu as il vit dans une
grotte cachée non j'allais rentrer chez
toi moi je sais que c'était génial c'est
que je dors je le rassure paris là c'est
trop loin j'ai mon vrai c'est vraiment
dur envers les maisons en fait moi je
prends de murat en plus élevées à cause
des travaux à 22h
c'est vrai sans déconner on dépense est
donc en vue de leur métier dans les deux
mois il se base de ces manants neuf
premiers mois je suis tombé c'est
magnifique avec les rhinos et que tu
peux parler de tout il est intéressé dès
lors un problème épineux
la vision politique du parti l'a fait
plus chaud c'est normal c'est donc c'est
vrai que l'agriculture intensive et
forcément il y aura un problème du
régime en civil total elle a vu son
enveloppe
on est bien vous voyez qu'il n'est pas
si méchant que ça dieudo je suis prêt à
voter de son public il sait pas ce qui
va avoir envie rennais je vais vraiment
sincère avec vous c'est réellement ce
que vous mettez dans le chapeau qui va
payer des artistes qui sont les artistes
part d'un que des humoristes mais ce
parti est évidemment de toute l'équipe
oui c'est vrai
des enfants jouent excusez-moi 3000 vies
mais
c'est la fin d'un glorious on va faire
la photo finale on va faire le finish on
a déjà perdu la moitié des artistes
donné leurs antennes
je joue mais qu il a deviné ce que
jamais deviner un jour c'est mental il
est mentaliste mécanicien dans une
enveloppe avant le spectacle j'avais
marqué 47 minutes parce que je savais
qu'il allait faire quand il exactement
franchement moi je sais à quoi je
conçois
ah oui d'accord veut que je fasse la
promotion la grande évasion dans sa tête
il est fort moi j'ai vu que j'ai vu sa
pièce la grande évasion à l'apollo
théâtre allez voir c'est un coup de
chance
moi je pense là non attends quand je
pense qu'à ça tu penses à quoi tu
pourrais penser
sion c'est un botaniste français total
et pour l'équipe de france
non mais ça va l'euro demeure prenait
voilà on sait pas précisément deviner
que ça doit invalider ce que j'ai
terminé je reste pas de vie sans lui
doit de finir son passage regarder merci
mec
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo vous
avez vous juge pas très bien réveillés
parce qu'en fait il l'est il est 6
heures du matin il faut absolument que
je montre la vidéo avant un rendez vous
important pour aujourd'hui si ça vous a
plu n'hésitez pas non plus à me faire
savoir en laissant un petit pouce en
l'air du lundi matin qui fait du bien et
sait plus ce que je veux dire oui en fin
d'après midi ou ce soir je mettrai une
petite question sur facebook par la
vidéo de jeudi sur la fanpage de
facebook lapierre lui car il n'était pas
y aller pour me donner votre sentiment
et voir ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
pour jeudi passé une très bonne semaine
et rendez vous demain à 17 heures pour
le prochain vendée globe
ciao